families across the road like they
didn't back in the day so they just
wasn't so it only only 40 of
um men have reproduced historically all
right it's either 40 or 60 I can't
remember off the top of my head but
there's a good portion of men that have
not reproduced there's a reason why I'm
watching this because essentially I
think traditional relationships
are polygenous and polygamous I actually
think those are traditional
relationships that human beings have
engaged in since I think I think for a
small percentage Yeah I don't think like
by and large like that makes sense for
societies but I think it does make sense
for the small percentages I think I
think the Western world came in if you
there's a book called um out of Edom by
a guy called him uh Robert barash and he
he and in that he shows that the
majority of humans
whether you go to Asia
Middle East Africa prior to the coming
of like the Western type of relationship
they were living in some kind of
polygamist or polygenous type
relationship and so if this new
um if this new type of one man and one
woman even though if you look at it
biblically there are certain people in
the Bible that had more than one you
know I mean if it's new
is it correct
but sorry like how many how many people
share baby fathers now that's what I'm
trying to say like and they will
actively know let's see me personally
for girls got if girls got a kid I don't
touch her like that's just me personally
I don't I don't think we want kids I'm
not gonna be this step I just know I
just don't do that that's something I
won't do
um so would you mean for long term you
mean oh well at this stage I know you
had sex with a woman who's got children
let's be honest no no so that's not
dating like what what like if you want
to get your back you wouldn't touch her
that's why I was like you know what I'm
saying I'm like no no okay okay okay let
me um let me reiterate rap
I'm still now I wouldn't now I wouldn't
touch up because I have no I just I
don't once you once I hear a kid I leave
that for the guys with the kids and you
know I mean I'm sick I don't have any
kids so why am I gonna entertain a woman
right okay and that's and that's my
thing and and that's my thing but
if a woman had a child there's no way
I'll be saying by another man that you
know I'm gonna give you another child
but women will happily have a baby with
a guy that they know it's got a baby
mother two other baby mothers and a guy
that left his woman already like or left
or like like there's difference between
a lot of a lot of times managers have
babies with girls and they just keep it
moving because he's in that top 20 yeah
but then you will still go and do that
so women always share baby fathers in
that because one guy will have one but
that's how women always fighting with
other women over the man yeah so that
polygamy thing they do it whether or not
they they do it conscious consciously
they accept it when they say you know
what you've got a kid I want to attract
you the moment a man says to you he's
got a kid you're supposed to tell him to
move on I don't deal with you but you
women will still chat to him the moment
you still chat to him it's the moment
you agree with it me personally you got
a kid now that's never gonna happen
because I know I'm not gonna be a
stepdad so you're saying people with
children should do with people with
children people without children to do
people without children yeah like see
blend in the family that's all good like
if you got if I got a kid you got a kid
you get together you know what I mean
Brady Bunch whatever you want to call it
but personally if I come out single I
hate being out in in single environments
and meeting people with kids because I'm
like where's your life listen I don't I
don't disagree I think you know I I
think everyone should set their own
standard yeah do you know what I mean
like if you don't want to do like if
women don't want to deal with me because
I've got a child so they they're going
to want to no but here's the thing
they're going to want to deal with you
that's the and and this is the real
thing in real life right A lot of times
I don't know your situation I don't know
if they they're full time with you
um but a lot of times is is a co-parent
okay there's no benefits for us being a
stepfather I said this in the last show
so if I come into your home and you have
a daughter or you have a son and you
know I want to move in with you if it
was going to be me and you we could have
maybe just bought a one bedroom it's
good to go but now I need to
automatically buy a two bedroom that's
what that was having a child right if
you want to have my own child we need to
have a three bedroom so automatically
now there's a cost incurred women always
say that you know what um it's not going
to be your responsibilities none of that
but you know if we live if the child's
in my house now it's under my provision
so so you know if I if I took out mice
let's say we both have kids now and I
used an example before I take my kid out
to Fort Park you know and you got your
kid there if I buy my kid you know
McDonald's in there if I buy my if I go
and win my kids things and then your kid
wants something I said actually no go
and get your father to buy it you're
gonna have a problem with that but
that's what I mean automatically that
child's gonna come across if he goes to
school and if I decide that I want to
send my kid to private school because I
have the funds for it but I told your
kid not to send tell his father to do it
women gonna have a problem with it if I
decide I want to buy my kids Jordans but
I want to buy your kids some actually I
don't tell you and this is the thing man
the thing is I've been for it what
you're talking about I've actually lived
it if you have a daughter and then you
know the daughter grows up in the future
and she's and she makes an allegation
against me are you gonna believe me as
the foot as the guy that's been in the
life for 10 15 years or are you gonna
automatically think that's a these are
the things can I discipline your child
the way I want to if we break up our
mind I'm still gonna have access to all
of these things are just too many
variables for a man that hasn't got kids
to deal with when I can just meet a
woman and we're not going to have any of
these issues so I think a lot of times
when women are are single yes and
they're single mothers they love their
children I understand that they just
don't understand how much life we're
talking about a new contract would you
guys be
um open to dating a guy with kids
um ladies and for me personally I'm not
at this stage howdy
I'm 29.
um yeah I'm 29 um but it's do you have
children no I don't have any children
but it's more about what if I would if I
was to get into that situation it is
knowing that I would eventually become a
stepmom so I want to know that I'd be
able to like you said provide it
children are expensive like I have niece
and nephews I took them out a couple
days ago it's a lot it's a lot so I but
I'm not I just yeah at this point in
time I wouldn't get into it because I
feel like I'd then become part of the
year you know what's so funny
Every Woman breaks their rules for the
work for the right guy
all right so there's no woman on this
planet that can make me come and stepdad
bro no I'm not saying man no I'm
listening when I hear that I'm like nah
I don't give a damn because I listen I
know Rihanna
but every woman breaks her rules for the
right guy what about you two
um what'd you do to get with kids yes or
no
or in general sure I'm not sure leaning
more towards no at the minute no okay
I don't see a problem with dating a man
with kids because if he's treating me
better than the man that hasn't got any
kids I don't see the problem do you know
the thing I've noticed is that when as a
man if you can show a woman that you are
actually a good father yeah I'd like
that though it works in your favor so
when as I said when women say oh no I
wouldn't date a guy with kids you meet a
guy and you can say oh my God he's such
a great dad like you're gonna start
thinking but what about our child he'll
be like that and that's how women start
thinking they start thinking oh my God
history our child great yeah no that's
definitely a thing right that's what I'm
trying to say yeah but I still I still
don't do the kids
I thought about it there's nothing that
bad about it I just think like it's
easier when you don't
I I found that my parents relationship
is easier because they've only dated
each other and they've only had kids
with each other and I just think it's
easier when there's not X's around right
whether it's on his end or her end right
I think it's easier now we're in 2022
it's it's it's wild you know as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible